the movie begins as we are introduced to
the protagonist named chev chev is a
skilled assassin who specializes in
killing elite and powerful people he
works for carlito an authoritative
ringleader of an enormous mexican cartel
at carlito's request chev had
assassinated kim a chinese competitor of
his employee which earned him many angry
foes one morning chev gets out of bed
and immediately starts to experience
some severe symptoms
his vision is blurred and he can barely
walk as he staggers to his living room
there he finds a video desk and plays it
on his tv on the tape ricky a fellow
hitman delivers a message to chef ricky
reveals that he injected the assassin
with a toxin in his sleep and discloses
that the poison will kill him within an
hour chev is outraged at hearing the
news and destroys the tv in frustration
he immediately races to his car and
speeds to a nearby club to look for
ricky on his way there he calls kylo his
street informant and asks him to find
the missing hitman to help him enact his
revenge while on the steering wheel
chev's heartbeat gradually slows down as
he struggles to keep his eyes open
luckily he manages to reach the club and
barges past the door chev immediately
seizes the club's owner and holds him at
gunpoint the assassin asks about ricky's
current location but the owner calmly
explains that he doesn't know chev is
disappointed by his answer and returns
to his car and speeds off a few minutes
later he calls his doctor named miles
chev explains his situation to him and
details the symptoms he's experiencing
after some thought miles reveals that
chev was injected with a poison known as
the chinese cocktail the toxin is
extremely fatal and shuts down
adrenaline production in the body miles
advises chef to keep moving to increase
his body's adrenaline production his
failure to do so would result in
immediate death the doctor also tells
him that he traveled out of town but
would return in a few hours jeff thanks
him for his advice and cuts the call
right then chev hears a loudspeaker
asking him to pull over and spots
multiple police vehicles behind him
seeing this he uses this as an
opportunity to pump up his adrenaline
instead of pulling over he ignores all
their commands and drives his car into a
mall as the officers chase after him in
hot pursuit he eventually crashes the
car into an escalator and escapes the
cops through a back door chev bursts out
into the street and races to a nearby
taxi he forcefully pulls out the
passenger and enters as he shouts at the
driver to speed off inside the cab chev
follows the doctor's instructions and
keeps moving as he aggressively bops his
head from side to side after a short
drive the cab pulls over at a nearby
supermarket and chev quickly enters it
he pulls the cashier across the counter
and threatens him with a gun jeff goes
around the store and collects a bunch of
energy drinks after which he returns to
the cab and heads to carlita's house
there he joins carlito in his pool and
converses with the cartel lord chev
discovers that carlito is aware of his
predicament and in fact even ordered it
it turns out that the cartel was being
attacked by the vengeful chinese gang
following kim's assassination hence
carlito decided to have chev killed to
make peace with the rival gang chev is
furious to hear this and leaves the
house as he returns to his waiting cab
he throws the cab driver to the floor
and steals the car racing off with it a
few minutes later he receives a call
from miles who offers him more tips to
combat the poison the doctor tells him
to get some shots of epinephrine a
synthetic version of adrenaline from a
hospital chev thanks the doctor for his
help and cuts the line as a call from
kylo comes in the informant tells him
that he spotted ricky's brother alex in
a nearby eatery and asks chev to come to
the location chev is delighted by the
news and instantly heads to the
restaurant he patiently waits outside
the premises for alex and immediately
attacks him as the man steps outside
chev amputates alex's hand with a
butcher knife and knocks him to the
ground the assassin grabs alex by the
caller and asks him about ricky despite
his injuries alex refuses to snitch on
his brother and instead tackles chev to
the ground kylo comes to chev's rescue
and hits alex on the head with a wooden
stick alex is distracted by the
informant and chev seizes the
opportunity to shoot him from behind a
few minutes later chev enters a hospital
and disguises himself as a patient he
walks calmly down a hallway but spots a
pair of officers in a ward and
immediately sprints off the officers
closely tail him however chev manages to
stay ahead of them as he dodges some
obstructing patients and races down a
flight of stairs he cites a group of
medics carrying a patient on a stroller
and rushes after them he seizes a nurse
and holds him at gunpoint as he asks for
an epinephrine shot the nurse is
frightened and frantically searches the
stroller cart for the drug luckily he
finds the vial and hands it to the
hitman who snatches it chev feels his
heart rate gradually slowing down and
devises a crazy plan to get it pumping
chev asks the nurse to shock him with a
defibrillator but the medic is hesitant
to do it however when chev points a gun
at him he succumbs to his demands and
blasts him with the device the shock is
immense and throws chef backward as he
falls into an elevator the officers
approach the elevator door to arrest
chaff but the hitman shoots at them as
they retreat and hide behind a wall chev
throws a patient out of the elevator and
shuts the doors as he heads downstairs
to finalize his escape while the
elevator goes down he uses a syringe to
draw from the vial and injects himself
sadly he takes an overdose of the drug
and immediately goes into overdrive as
he runs around the city hyperactively he
eventually stops when he sees a crowd
watching tv on the street and discovers
that the police have launched a
city-wide search for him we're talking
about jason statham on bath salts here
those police don't have a chance
meanwhile ricky gets word of his
brother's death as the men deliver
alex's severed hand to him ricky is
livid to discover that chef is
responsible and decides to find and
permanently kill him even though that
was already his plan in the other end of
the city chev is concerned about his
girlfriend eve and calls to check on her
he is relieved to hear her voice and
tells her he'll be at her house shortly
an unsuspecting eve doesn't think much
of it and kisses him goodbye and she
cuts the call a minute later chev spots
a policeman on a bike and grabs his gun
as he threatens the officer to back away
chev steals the bike and taunts the cop
by driving around in circles before
ultimately speeding to eve's house there
he urges her to get dressed and the
couple heads out of the apartment
outside he spots one of ricky's men and
trips eve's bag to distract her while
she picks it up chev attacks the thug
and snaps his neck before dumping him in
a nearby pool chev returns to eve and
the couple goes downtown to a local
restaurant so far a perfectly normal
date with statham while they wait for
their meal chev reveals to eve that he
is a professional assassin he explains
his current situation to her and informs
her that she is in grave danger eve is
startled to hear this and believes chev
made the story up to indirectly break up
with her livid she storms out of the
restaurant while chev closely follows
her he grabs her hand but immediately
feels his heartbeat slowing down as he
drops to the floor to kickstart his
heart chev asks eve to pump his
adrenaline by doing an activity in the
middle of the street eve initially
refuses and calls him crazy but gets
turned on when he kisses her eventually
the couple passionately do that activity
kickstarting his heart better than
motley crew ever could while the staring
crowd cheers them on right then chev
receives a call from kylo who informs
him that ricky is at a nearby warehouse
hearing this chev pulls his pants back
on and kisses eve goodbye before heading
off to the revealed location eve also
puts on her clothes as the spectators
disperse and continue with their
respective lives when chev reaches the
warehouse he finds carlito's men waiting
for him and discovers that kylo is dead
chev realizes that his boss carlito
ordered his assassination as the thugs
tortured kylo to lure him to the
warehouse an agitated chev shoots and
kills two of the men as a gunfight
ensues a few moments later chev spots
eve in the building's elevator and is
astonished to see her he immediately
races to the elevator while using kylo's
corpse as a shield from the thug's shots
however just as chef jumps into the
elevator a bullet hits him in the leg
the couple takes the lift to the ground
floor where a group of tailors are
sewing clothes chav ambush is one of the
thugs and shoves his hand into a sewing
machine the man screams in agony while
chev and eve leave the building as they
drive away in a stolen car carlito's men
also enter their cars and pursue the
couple in a fiery chase chev speeds away
in a quest to lose his foes but the
thugs are resilient and shoot at chev to
stop him luckily the shots only hit the
car's back window and chev quickly
returns fire his shots hit the men and
ultimately causes their cars to crash
after they complete their getaway chev
receives a call from miles who tells him
he's back in town jeff is relieved to
hear this and immediately heads to the
doctor's residence there miles gives him
an epinephrine infusion to further stall
the poison's progression however the
physician clearly explains to him that
there is no antidote for the toxin and
he's sure to die in a couple hours miles
offers to give him a painless poison to
help him die more easily but chev
refuses citing that he still has a score
to settle with ricky a few minutes later
chev calls ricky and asks him to meet in
a nearby hotel ricky accepts the offer
and agrees to meet him after which chev
cuts the call the hitman kisses eve
goodbye and promises to return as he
heads for the meeting venue chev loads
his gun in the hotel's bathroom and
hides it under his coat before entering
an elevator he goes to the top floor and
is welcomed by two of ricky's men the
duo aggressively collects his gun and
ushers him to ricky chev finds carlito
and ricky sitting side by side on a
couch after exchanging pleasantries
carlito pulls out a syringe containing
the chinese cocktail from his briefcase
carlito asks his men to hold jeff down
as he prepares to inject the hitman with
another dose of the poison thus killing
him for good however before the thugs
can make a move one of them is shot in
the head carlito's gang is shocked to
see this but soon realizes that a rival
gang standing behind chev took the shot
when carlito looks at the gang he is
astonished to discover that they are led
by kim in a flashback scene we see that
chev spared kim's life and asked the
gang leader to get out of town for a few
days kim obliged and word spread to the
streets that he was dead however he has
been alive and in hiding the entire time
pretty good twist for a movie this
stupid hence to show his appreciation
kim brought along his gang to save chef
from his cunning employer the chinese
mafia opens fire on carlito and his men
as the gang scatters to dodge the
oncoming shots ricky holds his gun to
shoot the rival gang but chev throws a
wine bottle at him which chops off his
fingers meanwhile carlito hides behind a
wall and calls his pilot to land a
helicopter on the roof a few seconds
later chev spots carlito as he leaves
the area and goes up a flight of stairs
chev closely follows the gang leader and
stops him just as he enters the
helicopter right then ricky sneaks
behind chev and injects him with the
second dose of the poison carlito
screams at ricky for ghosting him during
the shootout prompting the angered
hitman to shoot the ringleader in the
chest ricky throws carlito's body out of
the chopper and tells the pilot to start
the aircraft as the chopper takes flight
chev grabs the door and attacks ricky
the two men have a fistfight high up in
the sky and eventually fall from the
aircraft while in the air chev grabs
ricky's neck and sharply snaps it thus
finally completing his revenge mission
shortly after chav lands on a car and
bounces off of it as he drops to the
floor the movie ends as chev stares
wide-eyed at the camera hence signifying
that he is still alive still jason
statham and still a goddamn bald-ass
badass subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching